hallo deutschland am mittwoch schön dass
sie mit dabei sind
was macht der korona ausnahmezustand mit
unserer psyche
das beantwortet gleich unser heutiger
experte der psychotherapeut dr christian
lüdke außerdem in unserem corona kompakt
die auch die behörden mittlerweile
kreativ werden
denn in kleinen örtchen steißlingen bei
konstanz das glöckchen klingeln öffnet
sich ein stockwerk höher im rathaus das
bürofenster und dieses körbchen wird ihn
aufgezogen ob ausweisdokumente oder
meldebescheinigung hier gibt es alles
kontaktlos was ein bisschen an rapunzel
erinnert soll bürger und mitarbeiter vor
einer kurve 19 infektion schützen und so
bedienen schalter macher sieht lustig
aus ist aber tatsächlich sinnvoll denn
die korona pandemie breitet sich weiter
aus
nach erhebungen der johns hopkins
universität gibt es heute
deutschlandweit 100 7663 bestätigte
cupid 19 infektionen 36.000 81 menschen
haben sich davon wieder erholt doch auch
für diejenigen die sich bisher nicht
infiziert haben ist die lage oft
bedrückend sowie für 25 zirkusleute und
30 tiere des zirkus busch
sie sitzen seit über drei wochen
aufgrund des reise verbots auf dem
festplatz im hessischen fritzlar fest
ohne geld und mit kaum noch futter
rücklagen sind aufgebraucht und auch
kurzarbeit gibt es für schausteller
nicht finden
die ist natürlich sehr groß und die
leute kommen und melden sich telefonisch
oder per e mail
viele bringen neben geld auch
futterspenden und auch schausteller
familie landsmann trifft das corona
bedingte veranstaltungs verbot hart sie
verkaufen in der fünften generation süße
leckereien normalerweise auf jahrmärkten
doch not macht erfinderisch jetzt gibt's
in stuhr bei bremen popcorn gebrannte
mandeln und co eben am drive in
das gebrannte mandeln dass es
süßigkeiten gibt das dass wir jetzt so
was gerade in dieser zeit von taktlos
irgendwie hinbekommen haben dass die
kundschaft trotzdem ihre mandeln
bekommen kann
da bin ich ganz stolz drauf ob er und
viele andere betriebe diese krise
überstehen vermag heute trotzdem leider
noch niemand zu sagen
leere regale beängstigende nachrichten
ausgangs einschränkungen vielleicht
sogar angst um den job oder um die
gesundheit wie kommt man mit den sorgen
und ängsten rundum krone zu recht
unser gehirn ein hochkomplexes organ
1300 gramm wiegt diese schaltzentrale
die unseren gesamten körper steuert eine
billion nervenzellen sorgen dafür dass
der mensch zb sehen und sich bewegen
kann oder riechen schmecken und genießen
oder fühlen denken und lernen kann in
jeder sekunde werden zahllose reize auf
unsere festplatte im kopf die mit
solchen nachrichten gerade überflutet
wird
das corona virus grassiert weltweit und
sorgt für infizierte und viele tote
durch lungenentzündung die meldungen
beherrschen sämtliche medien
inzwischen meldet italien mehr als
10.000 tote und auch in großbritannien
steigt die zahl der opfer immer weiter
an
auf ihrer internetseite mahnt die
bundesregierung zur sozialen
distanzierung um die ansteckungsgefahr
für ältere zu reduzieren besorgnis macht
sich in der bevölkerung breit nennt man
mal dieses 81 und ich würde nicht
irgendwie in zwei wochen oder in drei
wochen auf dem krankenhausflur verdecken
sie im öfb ich gesagt für es daheim
bleiben wird gehamstert nudeln mehl und
stollen papier sind oft ausverkauft auch
das interessiert uns die ersten firmen
nähen provisorische spuck schutzmasken
privatleute ziehe nach in die
schutzausrüstung für häusliche pflege
rennen oder pflegepersonal in
altenheimen aber auch für ärzte und
krankenhauspersonal mit langsamkeit ohne
unschöne meldung nach der anderen
prasselt auf unser gehirn ein wann ist
die grenze erreicht
[Musik]
ja genau das fragen wir jetzt unseren
experten den psychotherapeuten dr
christian lüdke was macht denn corona
genau mit uns corona macht mit uns im
grunde genommen nichts anderes als reine
biochemie das heißt wir menschen
befinden uns unter hoch stress und unser
gehirn unser körper schaltet in einer
art überlebensmodus so wie in der
steinzeit also viele kämpfe oder
erstarren
und das bedeutet dass menschen an sich
jetzt symptome reaktionen erleben können
die sie so in der form nicht gekannt
haben von da ist es wichtig zu wissen
dass egal wie ein mensch jetzt reagiert
alle diese symptome und reaktionen sind
eine normale reaktion auf eine verrückte
situation
danke christian lüdke und wir sehen uns
gleich noch mal wieder wenn sie denn
einige unserer zuschauer fragen
beantworten werden
die sonne scheint und offenbar fällt es
vielen des wegen schwerer das
kontaktverbot einzuhalten auch in rheine
in nordrhein westfalen wird deswegen
noch häufiger kontrolliert für das
ordnungsamt sind frank lipka und niklas
placke unterwegs
das versammlungsverbot das kennen sie
rheine in westfalen
drei junge leute tauschen vor einem
drogeriemarkt handyvideos aus ein fall
für die ordnungshüter frank lipka und
niklas plake seid ihr eine familie in
diesem fall war es also dass es zwei
geschwister waren glaube ich und ein
bekannter ein freund das trio das kein
deutsch versteht verstößt gegen das
kontaktverbot
sie dürfen nur mit two people
zusammenkommen wird es bietet zwei meter
abstand halten dann ist das okay alle
drei entschuldigen sich bekommen einen
platzverweis und den guten rat zukünftig
den nötigen abstand einzuhalten denn die
sind voll verwahren wir erst mal wenn
wir jetzt im weiteren verlauf sehen dass
die leute sich jemand auch zusammen
aufenthalten wenn wir das geld aus
springen in rheine leben rund 80.000
menschen wegen der korona krise sind
spielplätze gesperrt und einkaufscenter
geschlossen
ich hab noch nie so leer gesehen muss
ich sagen also das ist schon auch von
dieser laute oder akustik das ist sehr
sehr sehr beängstigend so ein bisschen
muss ich sagen ja aber gut das sind halt
auch komische zeit mit hallo guten tag
die wenigen geschäfte die in der
innenstadt noch geöffnet bleiben dürfen
stehen im visier des ordnungsamtes die
abstände wo es dann ein bisschen enger
weder muss man immer noch mal darauf
hinweisen die kassiererin dass sie
nochmal ansagen machen vielleicht das
ganze geschäft bitte halten sie den
abstand ein wenn es mal ärger geben
sollte und sie gerne bei uns an oder bei
der polizei dann halt nächstes ziel von
frank lipka und niklas placke die
uferpromenade der ems der fluss ist ein
beliebtes ausflugsziel
sie kennen die regeln der wahrscheinlich
selber das kontaktverbot dieses trio
genießt das schöne wetter drei menschen
sind in zeiten von corona einer zu viel
doch die frau kann nachweisen dass sie
mit ihren beiden kindern unterwegs ist
wer jetzt eine fremde person generell
gewesen die nicht im haushalt leben dann
wäre es ein verstoß gegen das
versammlungsverbot gewesen und habe
stoffen bußgeld zahlen müssten in so
einem fall übrigens alle personen aus
einer gruppe denn auch diejenigen die
vom kontaktverbot normalerweise
ausgeschlossen sind also beispielsweise
familien
könne wenn sie die nähe eines fremden
freundes oder nicht familienmitglieds in
der öffentlichkeit dulden oder suchen
zur kasse gebeten werden
zehn minuten später rathausvorplatz im
visier der kontrolleure die nächste
dreier gruppe also gucken wir eben die
wiso zusammengehören ordnungsamt stadt
rheine
es geht ja das kontaktverbot in dem fall
war es jetzt so dass die person nicht
miteinander verwandt waren zumindest nur
zum teil die frau links im bild und der
mann in der mitte sind nicht und onkel
die dritte person rechts im bild ist ein
bestatter mit dem sich die familie wegen
eines beerdigungs termins auf der straße
getroffen hat auch wenn der anlass ein
trauriger ist streng genommen liegt hier
ein verstoß gegen das versammlungsverbot
vor
das ist jetzt ein grenzfall gewesen da
ist jetzt auch natürlich eine
außergewöhnliche situation heißt jemand
verstorben und da hat man wahrscheinlich
auch die gedanken woanders
die gruppe ist einsichtig die
ordnungshüter belassen es bei einer
verwarnung bilanz des kontroll tages bis
auf wenige ausnahmen halten sich die
bürger von rheine an das kontaktverbot
frank lipka und niklas plake hoffen dass
irgendwann die normalität in ihre stadt
zurückkehrt schönstes frühlingswetter
und ostern soll ja auch schön werden
eigentlich perfekt für die
tourismusbranche aber auch in den
bayerischen bergen der läuft gar nichts
da wo sonst um diese zeit ehrte viel los
ist in der zugspitz region da versuchen
sie das beste daraus zu machen
putzen die dörfer raus und bereiten sich
auf die saison vor die dann hoffentlich
irgendwann noch kommt
der gipfel ist menschenleer trotz
kaiserwetter stillstand bei den
skiliften der zahnrad und den seilbahnen
schon seit mitte märz die ganze region
touristen frei auch das bayern ressort
in grainau am fuße der zugspitze darf
keine gäste mehr beherbergen stattdessen
fliegt hotelbesitzerin christine barth
lechner jetzt bärlauch neuerdings hat
sie ausreichend von dem was sonst extrem
knapp ist zeit auch meine figur gut ist
es traumhaft schön mal entdeckt sachen
wo man sonst immer vorbei denn von den
sechs problem auswachsen und mark fried
sie so über jedes lebewesen wenn ihr
hotel wieder eröffnen darf werden auch
die gäste was von der auszeit haben
christine macht in der küche neben dem
frühstücksraum aus der frischen ernte
bärlauch butter ganz ungestört und
entschleunigt
immerhin ein bewohner ist noch da um die
fertige butter zu probieren tochter
barbara
gemeinsam machen sie das beste aus der
zwangspause auch der natur campingpark
isa horn in mittenwald hat vorübergehend
den betrieb eingestellt die 75 wohnwagen
der dauercamper stehen verweist herum
sie können und dekadente können
vorbeikommen nach ihrem wohl morgen
schauen aber mehr nicht
stattdessen geben helga und andreas half
das pächterehepaar jetzt vollgas bei den
renovierungs und umbauarbeiten
das restaurant soll isoliert und neu
verschalt werden
zusätzlich bekommen alle stellplätze
neue stromanschlüsse
warum jetzt eigentlich sehr viel
beschäftigung und können eigentlich gut
ausnutzen weil kennt aus dem weg ist so
schade drum aber andererseits das ist
der kleine vorteil jetzt von der ganzen
geschichte an ostern hätten sie hier am
ufer der isar die ersten zelt gäste
erwartet stattdessen gehört ihnen der
schöne blick jetzt
ganz allein am wank über partenkirchen
arbeitet die wirtin der thannen hütte
derweil an der guten laune der
einheimischen wanderer die vereinzelt
noch vorbeikommen immer wieder bemalt
anna hertle steine mit positiven
botschaften und legt nach wenn jemand
eins ihrer kunstwerke mitgenommen hat
jetzt haben wir das glück das wetter
schön ist positiv gestimmt bleiben
vielleicht mag ja ihr könnt auch für
sich zu hause einen stein einmal jan der
koch auf der hütte investiert der wahl
schon in die zeit nach der pandemischen
distanzierung einen eigenen
kräutergarten direkt neben seiner küche
wollte er schon lange haben kaufen und
direkt von sie wollen nach vorne schauen
und die ausnahme zeit aktiv gestalten
wenn die isolation mit diesem panorama
einhergeht fällt das wohl auch nicht
allzu schwer
der psychotherapeut christian lüdke ist
uns zugeschaltet und beantwortet jetzt
einige ihrer fragen zum beispiel von
frau geiges die trakt in diesen schweren
tagen von corona suche ich kontakte mit
anderen risikopatienten die der
einsamkeit müde sind es geht nur darum
miteinander zu sprechen wo kann man da
denn seriöse hilfe erhalten
seriöse hilfe findet man eigentlich
immer in der eigenen stadt
es gibt eine ganze reihe von
seniorenbüros von bürgerbüros ich kann
auch die karitativen einrichtungen vor
ort anrufen und im schlimmsten fall kann
ich mich auch an die telefonseelsorge
wenden und auch die krankenkassen bieten
eine ganze reihe von online hilfen an
wie erkläre ich meinen kindern das
ostern wie sie es kennen dieses jahr
nicht stattfinden wird die leiden
sowieso schon unter der jetzigen
situation ja den kindern dann muss man
es einfach direkt sagen ganz ruhig ganz
sachlich ostern ist anders aus ein
schild nicht aus und man sollte
versuchen möglichst viele der in der
familie bekannten rituale beizubehalten
oder dann eben in die wohnung ins haus
zu verlagern das heißt also wenn ich
vielleicht sonst mit oma und opa die
eier gesucht habe dann sollten wir das
diesmal im haus machen können vielleicht
oma und opa über fest haben
mit teilhaben lassen und sehen wie die
kinder sich dann freuen familie
heppelmann fragt das osterfest steht vor
der tür viele besucher gerade bei
risikopatienten können nicht stattfinden
das dann auch zu mehr depressiven
haltungen führt die können die
angehörigen am besten helfen
angehörige können am besten helfen wenn
sie einfach da sind wenn sie viel
telefonieren vielleicht auch hier
vielleicht auch mal brief schreiben was
ich ganz schön finde wäre wenn man als
angehöriger dann den geliebten menschen
mal einen richtig lieben brief schreibt
und richtig gefühle zum ausdruck bringt
es ist auch eine gute gelegenheit sich
gegenseitig mal zu vergeben und zu
verzeihen und damit dann die vorfreude
auf das wiedersehen zu vergrößern
ja vielleicht eine ganz gute gelegenheit
dazu dann hat uns noch folgende frage
erreicht je länger die kontaktsperre
dauert und je länger ich mit meiner
familie zu hause sitze vater mutter und
zwei kinder sind das fällt mir auf dass
der ton schärfer wird das kind
vielleicht einige und es schneller zu
konflikten kommt was können wir dagegen
tun
es ist normal dass der ton schärfer
werden kann wichtig ist immer nur dass
man sich darüber verständigt dass es
klare streit regeln gibt solange man
miteinander streitet und nicht
gegeneinander streitet ist es okay das
heißt am ende sollte man sich immer
vertragen was auch ganz gut ist wenn man
so eine art stoppsignal vereinbarte
quasi eine musikalische friedenspfeife
an macht das hat irgendein lied wenn ich
dieses lied spiele dann signalisiert es
den anderen komplett ich möchte mich
wieder vertragen lasst uns wieder ganz
normal miteinander umgehen
ok alex fragt ich arbeite seit drei
wochen im home office und bekomme
freizeit und arbeit immer weniger
getrennt ich sitze oft bis spät abends
am pc habe immer das gefühl sachen
gleich weg arbeiten zu wollen ist das
normal was kann ich tun
wichtig ist dass man sich auch zu hause
eine ganz klare struktur gibt
das heißt also normalerweise verlassen
wir irgendwann unser büro wir machen die
bürotür zu fahren nach hause
das sollten wir in veränderter form
jetzt auch im home office machen das
heißt tatsächlich den laptop zu klappen
die laptop tasche packen vielleicht
sogar ins kabuff weg stellen aus dem
sichtbereich das heißt also ich muss
auch mental die bürotür schließen können
gut ich hoffe das feld einfach danke an
dr christian lüdke und jeden tag kümmert
sich das hallo deutschland team ja um
ein aktuelles und informatives corona
kompakt das finden sie dann auch immer
über den kanal der ttf heute auf youtube
klicken sie gerne mal rein
oder wenn auch sie eine frage an unseren
experten haben schicken sie uns eine
mail an corona kompakte zdf de einige
davon können wir dann hier im studio
beantworten